[Music]  now got our reason to do crazy reckless  thing too much but if the reason is love  and maybe it's not so crazy right now  the only thing keeping me a lot  [Music]  I love you I never told my name before  this time I believe I have something you  want  they're gonna kill the love of my life I  can collect what I was doing you have  come back I knew it  she's big-time coffee for the Millican I  mean someone like you  is it dangerous okay  good morning Don line of work is quite  brutal and quite ruthless is that I  misjudged you  if anything's happened to work where I'm  in one when people by the feel for me  any innocent itís by violence and  meaningless death I'm coming to get you  [Music]  Nikki big even one  hey stay cool man  oh this come enormous day but now  some people think what I did was kind of  like romantic kind of romantic  [Music]  you